hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
this week I've been attempting to find
the perfect sensitivity to endorse for
people playing for at night battle
royale I've tried using sent one one all
the way up to ten ten but I now know for
certain it's impossible to say one way
of playing is superior to another so
instead I've put together this guide to
help you find your ideal settings please
share your sensitivity in the comments
below and of both those you agree with
let's see what the general consensus is
here well look at a handful of pro
players on console that will break down
a bit of the science and look for some
tips and tricks to help you make your
final decision
but first let's quickly make sure we're
all on the same page with the definition
of sensitivity on console this is
completely about how much movement and
pressure we apply to our thumbs whilst
gaming this is always split into two
axis the x and y if you're having a hard
time remembering which is which a great
way to remember is by using your head
literally not your head like you're
saying yes that's the y-axis so the
first letter of yes is Y get the idea
when you were last at school you may
have gotten an answer wrong and to
symbolize that the teacher would write
an X or a cross and they'd probably
shake their head at you to use that to
remember the x axis generally there are
two trains of thought in fortnight high
sensitivity will give you the edging
build battles and close up combat low
sensitivity will see you control medium
to long range encounters our plan today
is to find your settings to be able to
keep a foot in both camps so let's crack
on let's look at the sensitivity of a
few pro gamers and youtubers to get a
grasp of the key differences in play
style probably the most well known ps4
player is Nick mercs who is so good he
can beat professional PC players using
mouse and keyboard Nick uses a mid
sensing with 6 for both X and y-axis he
formerly used default 5 5 X&Y settings
but like most people over time his style
developed he's well aware that he's not
the greatest build battler in the lobby
and openly admits that his edit game
isn't anywhere near PC players but what
he gives away in
building style he makes up for with
accuracy which is second to none
his playstyle is offense and quick kills
favoring attack shotgun over a pump he
also uses a pro controller to jump using
his left middle finger therefore his
right thumb never leaves the stick when
aiming down sights are using a scope his
sensitivity is 0.5 but I've seen him use
other ones in the past half the
sensitivity on offer in the main point
here this aim sensitivity is set up for
mid to long range encounters perfect to
complement his shotgun game from all
this information we can assume that Nick
is heavier handed than most players and
uses large thumb movement to achieve an
extraordinarily high level of play
yeah oh my god thank you another
world-class console player who recently
destroyed a PC server with 32 kills
using a controller is up shop this beast
of a player doesn't use the right thumb
sticks to Crouch instead he's a little
more old-school and utilizes the claw
technique in terms of settings
Upshaw uses six tick sensitivity just
like Nick mercs but his aiming down the
sights stays higher at 0.65 meaning
again his building isn't his priority
those kills are the 0.65 aiming
sensitivity allows for perfection at
medium range with only marginal drop-off
at long distances he has another trick
up his sleeve for long range encounters
utilizing the aim assist but we'll get
to that soon I promise on the flip side
of those players who want high kill high
tempo games is Alex Raimi gaming best
known for having a record number of
SolarWinds on consoles alex utilizes a
max sensitivity of 10/10 meaning the
smallest movements in his thumbs are
recognized as large movements by the
console I know it can sometimes look
like he's using a sim controller and a
mouse and keyboard but I've seen enough
evidence to believe him that he's on a
controller
Alex place four wins rather than kills
so he keeps out of danger until the
final circle where his build speed keeps
him on top that's 10/10 sensitivity is
all about getting the high ground
his 80s on scope sites are running at
point six five one point six five making
him accurate at all distances especially
medium range and of course he can jump
around with a shotgun with the best of
them
and let's check out the king of
clickbait himself ali-a that's enough of
that
surprisingly Ali plays at default by
five settings giving him an advantage at
range a little more surprisingly though
his abs and scope sensitivities are 0.6
and 0.7 making them quicker than you'd
expect from watching his gameplay he
appears to regularly change his settings
which makes sense for a player who
played other games as well as fortnight
yes it's possible to play more than one
game as a quick note Ali is another one
of those who use a pro controller to
keep the edge when in bunnyhop battles
you know what I'll include myself on
this list to keep the skill level
decreasing I favor an 8 to 7 sensitivity
with ABS around 0.55 and scope around 6
mine are a little funky so let me break
them down it may sound strange having
disproportionate X and y-axis but in my
previous life I used to look at video
game development and over the years I've
had a small insight into thumbstick
acceleration let's break it down look at
your thumb which is the easier motion
for you moving it left to right on the x
axis or up and down on the y axis
hopefully you said left and right is
easier and that's because a huge portion
of your hand is dedicated towards
supporting that motion whereas the
up-down motion is a little harder to
control due to the muscles used since
thumb sticks were introduced the y axis
the up and down one was accelerated to
feel closer to the x axis so before we
even choose our own sensitivity always
be mindful that it's highly likely the
up-down motion is already a point or two
higher than the x axis I don't want to
go too far with that so I hope that
makes sense let me know if I need to
break it down any more anyway let's move
on before things become too technical
here's the question so how the heck do
we figure out which sensitivity we
should use well there are a few drills
we can try out in playground mode or if
that's down pick a game mode and fly to
the edge of the map for some alone
the first drill is designed to test your
x-axis movement find a tree a lamppost a
telegraph pole and aim your reticle at
it but don't aim down the sights we'll
get to that I promise for now move to
your right and attempt to keep the
cursor in the middle of that object
count how many times it drops out in
around five seconds now go back the
other way and count the mistakes try
this at different distances if there is
no chance that you can keep control
now's a great time to try other
sensitivities once you're settled and
happy try the whole thing with more pace
in fact change up your movement to truly
test yourself if you're happy now we can
introduce the up-down motion into the
mix which will test your y-axis skills
on top of your X it's not easy is it
don't worry though we aren't looking for
perfection just control so stay around
the target impossible so now we'll bring
in hipfire and a little building
generally it's accepted that higher
sensitivity is needed for building but
that also reduces quick-fire accuracy
with weapons so we want our sensitivity
to be as high as possible without losing
confidence in our shot now we're going
to build up a little before taking shots
for added muscle memory training attempt
to jump from a ramp and aim with your
shotgun to destroy items in the world
when I say aim I'm referring to hipfire
when in close combat I personally like
the motel at the north of the map as it
has these parasols to practice with if
you're using a standard controller this
drill will test your ability to jump and
then return your thumb to the stick to
fire with accuracy if you play claw or
use a pro controller still give this a
go and try to count how many shots you
land in a row so now we're getting a
feel for our sensitivity at any point
you want to switch up the sensitivity
but keep in mind whatever you settle on
will take time to learn and will
probably change in the future
here's a crucial point make sure you are
aiming both left and right it's
important as you'll see which is your
dominant side it's like handwriting
right or left one always feels more
comfortable learn which is your favorite
position and plan better in battle try
the whole thing with different weapons
such as a spam weapon like a drum gun
another thing to note here is that the
aim function is set to favor right-sided
players is an example here
I can aim off the right-hand side of my
ramp but if I try this on the left it's
simply impossible so always keep that in
mind your strength is your right hand
side so at this point we can aim and
move we can build and fire from the high
ground we can jump and flick shop with
the best of them but at this point we're
still shooting inanimate objects now's
the time to figure out our ad s setting
sadly we can't do this alone
as Amos issed plays a huge part in
aiming on console let's quickly outline
aim assist or aim resist as many people
call it without a doubt we need a missus
Tonkin sold it basically acts like a
stabilizer once you're aimed in and
start shooting if you have going up
against the keyboard and mouse player
aim assist is the single advantage a
console player house and keep in mind
everyone in the server has it switched
on so you may as well utilize it too the
reason why I call it a mist is due to
the issue we looked at a few months back
if you start shooting just behind an
opponent the aim assist kicks in and
actively prevents you from catching back
up with your enemy and completely dense
your confidence the M assists have been
tweaked and updated many times in the
last six months making it now possible
to reacquire your target by disengaging
for a split second taking your finger
off both the aim and fire triggers then
a millisecond later reapplying them
instantly your target should be back in
your sights going back to Upshaw his
trick is to almost spam the aim trigger
for ultra quick target acquisition he
also takes single shots with ARS to
maximize first shot accuracy Crouch
accuracy and aim assist all in one he's
got so good at it he's been accused of
using aimbot just look at these skills
so back to aiming down sights and
sensitivity I'm sure you've already
noticed the aim assist randomly kicks in
when someone jumps past you in the lobby
the reticle almost follows the target
for a split second this is the key to
finding your aim sensitivity for drills
you'll want to invite friends into
playground mode or I prefer to get
behind the enemy in a fifty versus fifty
match to practice aiming and following a
target are you able to keep your reticle
on a running
me or a running and jumping enemy or a
building enemy like always try different
distances but here's the kicker
just before you shoot release and
reengage the aim trigger to add a
smidgen more accuracy to your shot
pretty cool isn't it
it definitely works it just takes a bit
of time to practice it's pretty cool
when it does work right let's look at
other ways to get the edge in a fight
with a few tips and tricks to consider
aim assist is godly but there are other
ways to find an advantage going back to
ali-a he uses button remapping to change
the aim and fire triggers from the
typical r2 and l2 bringing them forward
to r1 and l1 this theory is pretty damn
simple the amount of time your finger
takes to push the trigger down is
considerably longer than using a button
you can literally shoot faster by
switching the trigger to the button in
front similarly many players change r3
to jump to allow them to aim whilst
jumping in the air as we saw earlier
jumping and aiming on a standard
controller is nigh on impossible unless
you use a pro controller or use the
fabled claw technique speaking of pro
controllers I've recently reviewed a
scuff impact to see how it gives an
advantage in fortnight it's worth a
watch if you want to see what all the
hullabaloo is about there's also a small
advantage to be had by turning off
vibration as it can impair your hands
for a split second especially if you use
high sensitivity but starting to move
away from the term sensitivity now so
I'll bring the video to an end hopefully
this has given you an insight into your
perfect settings on console please keep
in mind it can take up to 600 hours for
muscle memory to be perfected so don't
give up after an hour or two keep
tweaking your inputs over days weeks and
months until you're completely happy
with your decision and always remember
play style will dictate your sensitivity
are you a master builder or a shotgun
bunny are you a mid-range battler or a
sniper do you rush or do you play slow
there's so many ways to approach bot
night and to approach console
sensitivity oh we did it thank you for
your time I'm Adam from Playstation
grenade I hope that's helped I'll catch
you next time
[Music]